this video was sponsored by fast hosts
who are offering uk viewers the chance
to win
a 5 000 tech bundle if you can answer my
techie test question
later in the show on may 1st 2015
a group of scientists predicted that the
following november
we would see a star go supernova
billions of light years away
in a spiral galaxy designated sp1149
this was the first time anyone had ever
tried to predict
a supernova and for good reason they are
incredibly rare and unpredictable for a
star larger than eight times the mass of
our sun
a supernova marks the end of its life
cycle running out of fuel in its core
the star collapses in on itself and then
in the ensuing crush of matter
it violently explodes a supernova can be
as bright as a whole galaxy
and importantly the light emitted
follows a predictable pattern
it glows brightly for weeks and then
fades down over a period of months
but supernovae are rare in any galaxy of
a hundred billion stars or so
you can expect on average only two per
century
so just try picking the star that's
going to explode
now we can say how long a given star
will live based on its mass luminosity
and color temperature
these data pinpoint its stage of life in
a predictable life cycle
but the estimate of exactly when a large
star will go supernova
has big error bars take the red
supergiant beetlejuice for example
in our own milky way galaxy it is a
great candidate to go supernova
scientists think beetlejuice will
explode any day now in the next few
hundred thousand years when it does
it'll be so bright you can see it in the
daytime
and it will rival the full moon's
brightness at night
compared to the lifespan of a star a
hundred thousand years
is a brief window of time but for us
short-lived humans it may as well be
forever
so you might think it would have been a
tough sell when the scientists who
predicted we'd see a supernova in
november 2015
asked for time on the hubble space
telescope to take pictures of galaxy
sp1149
but their request was granted
they could image this part of the sky
roughly once a month starting on october
30th
before this the galaxy was too close to
the sun to point hubble at it
in this first image taken at the end of
october there is no supernova
the next image was taken on november
14th
again no supernova but in the third
image
taken on december 11th jackpot there's a
supernova
right where they predicted it would be
and almost exactly when they said it
would happen
so how did they manage to predict a
supernova almost
to the month well the truth is they had
seen
this same exact supernova before
not once not twice but four additional
times a year earlier and five months
before the predictions
hubble took this image see those four
bright dots
those are multiple images of that same
supernova
the reason we see the same supernova in
four different locations
is because there is a lens between us
and the exploding star
not a lens made of glass of course but a
gravitational lens
made of a huge amount of ordinary matter
and dark matter
gravitational lensing tends to magnify
distant sources
and increase their apparent brightness
as rays of light become concentrated
this smears the image of distant
galaxies into arcs
strands and all kinds of weird shapes
and of course
to some distant observer in another
galaxy the light from our own sun and
milky way galaxy may be similarly warped
in gravitational lensing there are three
essential components
the source the lens and the telescope
if the lens and the source are
spherically symmetric and if the source
lens and telescope
are perfectly aligned you get what's
known as an
einstein ring the light from the source
is bent around the lens equally
in all directions leading to the image
of a smeared out ring
if the source and the lens are
spherically symmetric but are not
perfectly aligned then what we end up
seeing is a break
in the einstein ring it splits into two
semi-circles
and if the source lens and telescope are
aligned but the lens is not
axially symmetric for example it could
have an elliptical shape
well then you get four images in the
shape of a cross
an einstein cross so what happened with
our supernova
is 9.3 billion years ago
a dying star in a galaxy far far away
went out with a bang
as a supernova the explosion sent out a
blast of light in all directions
about five billion years ago before the
earth even existed
that light encountered a very massive
object that warped
space-time it was a cluster of galaxies
called
macs j1149.5 plus
2223 yeah i know that's a mouthful but
the name just tells us where in the sky
it was discovered by the massive cluster
survey
this galaxy cluster is made up of lots
of massive substructures like
individual galaxies and halos of dark
matter
at some point as the light traveled
through this region it encountered an
elliptical galaxy
almost perfectly lined up with where the
earth would eventually be
and the gravitational deflection focused
light rays that were initially diverging
onto paths that converged at the earth
this is why we saw the same supernova in
four different locations
not only did the supernova appear at
four different places the images also
appeared at different times
relative to the first image the others
were delayed by periods ranging from
five days to
over three weeks and we could measure
this time delay because of the
distinctive light curve
of the supernova some of the images of
the explosion were further along in
their light curve than others
this was a particularly lucky discovery
it's the first time a multiply lensed
supernova has ever been observed
there are other objects that due to
gravitational lensing appear multiple
times on the sky like
multiple images of galaxies but these
objects don't change predictably with
time
so there's no way to use their images to
work out the relative time delay between
them
now one reason for the time delay
between the supernova images
is because the four paths the light took
were different lengths
so it just took the light longer to
travel further
but there is another reason which is
that light passing through curved
space-time
appears to travel more slowly relative
to an external observer
this is much less intuitive but it's a
well-established
and well-tested part of general
relativity back in 1964
irwin shapiro suggested it would be
possible to test this gravitational time
delay
by sending radar signals to venus and
measuring how long it takes for the echo
to come back
he calculated that due to the
gravitational influence of the sun
the signals would take an extra 200
microseconds
when venus was on the other side of the
sun compared to when it was close to us
this is solely a gravitational time
delay not related to the extra distance
the light has to travel
and within a couple years experimental
data revealed
the gravitational time delay for light
traveling past the sun
was exactly as predicted today
in order to accurately determine the
distance to the voyager and pioneer
spacecraft
this shapiro time delay must be taken
into account
now i want you to have a look at the
four supernova images again
do you notice how the same galaxy
appears three times
in this image that is the supernova's
host galaxy
it is itself lensed by the massive
galaxy cluster nacs j1149.5 plus
two two three in fact this cluster
lenses tens of galaxies so scientists
had been studying and
modeling the distribution of matter in
the cluster long before the supernova
they asked if we see these four images
of the supernova in one
image of its host galaxy when would the
supernova appear in these
other two images of the host galaxy and
using the models of mass distribution
and
general relativity they calculated that
in this image
the supernova would have appeared 20
years earlier
in 1995. now there are no close-up
pictures of this part of the sky from
1995 so
there is no way to check but in the
other image of the galaxy
they predicted the supernova would
appear again in about
one year's time almost exactly
when it showed up in that hubble image
this successful prediction is a
fantastic confirmation of our
understanding of light and gravity
on the scale of the whole universe but
it has even bigger
implications one of the hottest debates
in astronomy right now is
how fast is our universe actually
expanding
this is measured by the hubble constant
the rate at which distant galaxies are
receding away from each other
depending on their distance apart now
there are two main ways this measurement
has traditionally been made
one is to look for stars in the nearby
universe
whose absolute luminosity we know then
we can use how bright they appear to us
to determine how far away they are if
you combine this distance information
with how red-shifted their light is
you can work out how fast the universe
is expanding
this is known as the distance ladder
method and the value of the hubble
constant it produces
is around 74 kilometers per second per
megaparsec
meaning for every megaparsec that
separates two galaxies
they will on average be moving apart at
74 kilometers per second
the other way to measure the hubble
constant is to study the features
in the cosmic microwave background
radiation which is
essentially just a picture of the early
universe using the standard model of
cosmology which is called lambda cdm
we can work out how this early universe
picture would expand over time
the result obtained from this method
comes out to 67 kilometers per second
per megaparsec
substantially slower than the 74 found
via the other method
now over the years both of these
techniques have been refined
reducing their uncertainties but the
values
have not gotten closer together so at
this moment
the two values really seem different
they are
on the cusp of being a five sigma result
astrophysicist joseph silk has called it
a possible crisis for cosmology
but there are independent ways to
measure the hubble constant and one of
them
is to look at a multiply lensed
supernova and use the time delay between
their appearances
to work it out this was first proposed
by a norwegian astronomer sierra
refstall in 1964.
since this is the first observed
multiply lensed supernova it has become
known as
supernova ref stall calculations of the
hubble constant from this data
yield a value of 64 kilometers per
second per megaparsec
now although that result has large error
bars it is more in line with the
measurements of the cosmic microwave
background radiation than with the
distance ladder method
the thing i keep thinking about is how
strange
space is i mean i used to think of it
essentially like glass
fundamentally transparent with some
foggy regions or some slight distortions
but here we have space warping light on
multiple
curved trajectories making the same
event appear
in six different places on the sky
separated by
days weeks a year and 20 years
and what is contained in those
distortions is information about the
workings
of our entire universe
hey this video is sponsored by fast
hosts who are offering uk viewers the
chance to win
a 5 000 tech bundle including your dream
pc setup
if you can answer my techie test
question now fast host provides
a wide range of web hosting products if
you're in the uk
and you're looking to start a podcast or
a blog or a business
you're going to need a website and fast
hosts have got you covered they offer
easy registration for
a huge range of domain names with
powerful management features
included plus they have a website
builder
with drag and drop templates you can
create a custom
mobile optimized website with no coding
required
get up to three months free and if
you're not satisfied in the first 30
days
you can cancel without paying a penny
now on to my techie test question
which famous scientist criticized
newtonian gravity by saying
that gravity should be innate inherent
and essential to matter
so that one body may act upon another at
a distance through
a vacuum without the mediation of
anything else
is to me so great an absurdity that i
believe
no man who has in philosophical matters
a competent faculty of thinking
can ever fall into it if you know the
answer who said that
and you live in the uk click the link
below for your chance to win
the ultimate tech bundle i want to thank
fast hosts for sponsoring this video
and i want to thank you for watching